Bruce you can't keep doing this step out  of the shadows don't let tombstones be  your family legacy  I know you're trying to create a myth  just remember there is room for Bruce  and Batman inside that suit  this city has burned with corruption and  greed but Bruce's help a vote for Harvey  Dent is a vote to finally put your foot  down Vicki Vale reporter for the Gotham  Gazette is the dent campaign soliciting  votes from Gotham's biggest crime family  money gets money I can get Harvey the  mayor or I can pull it out from under  your father despised men like Falcone no  one has ever managed to bring him down  I haven't tried yet  come on a fire is heading this way you  must show the world the true nature of a  wade sometimes I think this whole city's  our crime scene  revolution is knocking on Gotham store  when there's whole thing stars make sure  you're on the right side  well then time to save the city  you